Our greatest innovations are the creation of brands
that can make a difference in our lives
and reflect the kind of world that we want to live in.
In November of 2016,
Krista Suh, Jayna Zweiman and Kat Coyle
created a hat to be worn at the Women's March in Washington, DC.
(Applause)
This was the day after the presidential inauguration.
Two months later, on January 21, 2017,
millions of people all over the world wore handmade pink pussyhats
in support of the Women's March all over the world.
The hat was not created for any financial benefit.
Like our religious symbols created thousands of years ago,
the hat was created by the people, for the people
to serve what I believe is the highest benefit of branding:
to unite people in the communication
of shared ideals.
The pink pussyhat became a mark for a movement.
In a very short time, two months,
it became universally recognizable.
It connected an audience in an unprecedented way.
It is a brand,
but it is more than that.
Today, the pink pussyhat is proof positive
that branding is not just a tool of capitalism.
Branding is the profound manifestation of the human spirit.
The condition of branding has always reflected the condition of our culture.
It is our responsibility
to continue to leverage the democratic power branding provides,
and it is our responsibility
to design a culture that reflects
and honors
the kind of world we want to live in.
Thank you.
(Applause)